speaking in berlin the leaders of
germany france and poland say their
common goal is to prevent a war in
europe the french president had just
flown in from kiev where he met his
ukrainian counterpart hoda abdel hamid
has
more
it was the first visit by a french
president in 24 years
emmanuel macron in kiev after holding a
five-hour marathon meeting with russia's
president vladimir putin in moscow on
monday
our goal for coming weeks and months is
to have a stabilization of the situation
and to kick start through new guarantee
mechanisms a lasting de-escalation in
this context the cool-headedness you
have shown the restraint that all
parties have shown in word indeed are
essential
france also pledged 1.3 billion dollars
to help stabilize the economy signing
deals to improve some of the
infrastructure around the country
but with no sign of de-escalation yet
ukraine continues to prepare for the
worst case scenario
ukrainian troops are to hold military
drills around the country starting
february 10th
this same day russia and belarus are due
to start phase two of their joint
exercises
the ukrainian military will be
displaying some of the weapon we
received from nato members
its army has grown from 6 000 to nearly
150 000 combat-ready troops and the
country has also upgraded its own
military industry
yes we can cover our needs when it comes
to anti-tank weapons for land air and
mobile units we also produce several
types of tactical weapons
but for now it's diplomacy that is
prevailing even though president
zielenski is being cautious dampening
perhaps a little of the optimism shown
by emmanuel macron
i don't trust words in general every
politician's sincerity appears in their
specific steps in our case the sincerity
is the escalation i believe that putin
has everything to do this especially as
this person is very sincere as i
understand
i don't know an entity in europe who
would be able to put strong pressure on
russia the occupation of our country is
still not happening
it seems all parties have agreed to
continue talking
al jazeera kiev